fisher está a un paso de la aprobación
final para su distribución en eeuu un
comité asesor de la fd dio su visto
bueno a la dosis para un uso de
emergencia con 17 votos a favor 4 en
contra y una abstención- facer y 20 que
reciben el voto de comité asesor de la
sda para respaldar la posible primera
autorización de uso de emergencia de la
vacuna para combatir el kobe 19 en eeuu
si los funcionarios de la fed dan el
visto bueno final al producto es muy
probable que su reparto masivo por el
país comience la semana que viene
durante estos días decenas de hospitales
de la unión americana están recibiendo
los paquetes de preparación de las dosis
para agilizar el proceso una carrera
contrareloj que supondrá todo un desafío
tecnológico y logístico ya que eeuu
tiene aseguradas 25 millones de dosis y
la temperatura a la que deben ser
conservadas no debe superar los menos 70
grados centígrados en nueva york' esta
red de hospitales tiene ya listos sus
congeladores para guardar miles de dosis
al día
todo este congelador puede contener un
par de cientos de miles de dosis
esperemos que sólo lleguemos a albergar
unas miles inicialmente y tal vez unas
cinco mil en algún momento por lo tanto
para ser absolutamente eficientes no
será como llenar el congelador de casa
la vacuna elaborada por la compañía
moderna también tiene previsto recibir
el visto bueno la próxima semana algo
que ayudaría a que eeuu se acercarse más
a la inmunidad colectiva y al final de
una pandemia que ha matado a casi
300.000 personas en el país